yeah you've done like the Spartan Race
you've done the chest boxing have you uh
relapsed uh oh yeah
I mean it's yeah everyone's been like
Chris every video I put out people like
analyze it they're like has he put on
weight or not in the comments like Chris
looks great or Chris looks marginally
fatter again oh [__] you know [__]
whatever I do I do I think I put on a
little bit more weight because I haven't
been doing all but you're way you're way
better than you yeah yeah yeah
absolutely feel a lot fitter and like
when I did the cycle the second cycle
with Connor like I I hadn't trained for
three months yeah the stamina was still
there yeah yeah and the Spartan Race a
few weeks ago and I was able to get
through that and then next week climbing
[__] Mount Fiji again which I haven't
never thought I would do but um doing
that again you're dressing right for the
engaging this time not going in [__]
sure not sleeping on a rock or even a
rock I think I just need to have the air
ambulance on speed dial because nasty
natsuki's gonna do it right oh [__] he's
50 or he will be August 9 as he likes to
say my birthday Nagasaki bomb because uh
he always tells me that it's a great way
to remember when his birthday is for
better or worse but uh yeah he's been
cycling because I I'm like are you
actually gonna climb Mount Fuji that's
he's like yeah no problem it's like you
can't get up the stairs
he because he smokes like 30 40
cigarettes a day yeah 20 cigarettes a
day minimum right his lungs just cannot
be operational yeah and like 3 700
meters up it's like oh there's less
oxygen here and what's gonna happen but
he has been cycling every day 40
kilometers oh damn that's not bad
providing he's not lying I'm encouraged
do you think he's lying I watched him
cycle for 10 minutes and he did look
quite wrecked by the end of it maybe
he's like today only four kilometers
when I was there oh yeah
I never thought I'd climb Mount Fuji
again like there's that saying right A
wise man climbs about Fuji once a bell
end climbs it twice
in Japanese you'll know it what right
surprise a wise man climbs about Fuji
once an idiot a fool climbs it twice
it's my own contemporary take on it
right yeah
for Japan and the reason is because it's
not a fun climb it's a big black
volcanic Wasteland up there there's no
like oh it's nice scenery there's crowds
of people the wind is bad the
temperature goes from hot to freezing
yeah and it's just not really fun
um but people do it obviously for that
once a lifetime view of the sun coming
up which you can't get from anywhere
else apparently oh from literally
anywhere yeah yeah a wise man climbs
Fuji once only a fool claims at twice
why apparently that's the same okay so I
mean I guess it makes sense because yeah
it's but the thing is it's not actually
translated correctly from the Japanese
one the Japanese one is you're a full if
you don't climb Mount Fuji once you're
also a full if you climb it twice okay
okay one and done just do it once yeah
just do it one and done so I'm not a
fool right now zero zero is full one is
fine too I'm saving it so you're the
only one that's not a fool right I'm not
a fool but I will be what if it's three
times did you just go back to normal
again it's like every other time it's
like you're an idiot you're fine you're
an idiot you're fine a legend
I think we [__] cycled up like four
three weeks in uh in uh when we were
doing the Kyushu cycle that was [__]
quite possibly wait so why are you
climbing up Fuji again
[Music]
than an air ambulance Mount Fuji um and
also to kind of promote the book because
the book cover uh has like Fuji on the
front yeah
it's a book about Japan exactly right
there's no other way
um and uh
yeah I I'm gonna try and do like a book
signing the summit Mount Fuji water
stains have sent me like a banner right
British bookstore if there goes in and
I'm gonna stand there with a pile of
books yeah just hand them out to anyone
who'll take pretty much yeah please
books can you carry up there well I've
got like you know they'll be ASCII you
can carry them yeah four books is even
like heavy you're like that's oh I have
my luggage meal
in all of Japan in the same way Pete
comes on the cycles for the back rubs
natsuki's coming to carry my books I
need I need this that's the reason why
he's gonna have an air ambulance right
it's not a mountain it's not bugs the
broken bark yeah just a broken they ship
to the top could you ship it to them
yeah Yamato guy up there like where do
you go like air ambulance to the top
there are some weird things to talk
about food there's vending machines very
cool I'll take some of the magic away
it's like wow that's ethereal Mountain
it's been here for a hundred million
years
you get to the top you're like I'm
parched it's a vending machine
like it's like it's like if you were
stuck in the Oasis in a desert and then
you you know you come along this you're
like oh I need
some water and then Over the Horizon you
just see like a [__] picari sweat
machine you'd be like oh yes and then
you have no coins
just just imagine the guy like refills
that every day yeah he must be the
fittest
yeah yeah right just be like oh you got
to go refill it can you take these off
by the way just leave them up there yeah
you know how there's like in every kung
fu movie there's like a secret like
Grand Master that's like training in the
mountains it's just the [__] guy
bring up the pukary school man's
definitely taking off the sanzu
there's something worse than that when
you get to the fifth station which is
the typical starting point for the climb
yeah there's a shop that sells cans of
air from the summit of Mount feet so
there's literally someone whose job is
to go up to the summit be like
and then walk down again
from the summer actually tried buying
one of those like it wasn't even one of
the cans it was literally a plastic bag
right so someone had gone up to the top
of Mount Fuji just went and just like
tied in a plastic bag and a thousand yen
please I could make a profit from this
trip
and then I'll use the bags to bag the
air yeah
it's the book with inside a bag with the
air of the song of the mouth imagine my
face when I get when I go to the door
for a delivery one day I open it the
postman gives me like
well it feels like an empty box I open
it and it's just a [__] bin bag
you try to open the bin bag it's like
what is it rip lose that precious hair
what a weird Mountain but like I've seen
photos of the crowns this year and it is
a joke because it's the first year I
think it's properly officially open so
it's right outside world and it looks
like the world's biggest theme park
right there's photos of at night right
where everyone using lights you can see
Fuji and then the top third there's a
sneaking line of lights no and it's just
like oh God but Ace up my sleeve good
friend of mine Victor frame of travel
you guys know yes uh he climbed Mount
fuja every year see the summit I thought
he did it in one day and I was like
Victor you're a God have you done this
but he doesn't like six days which is I
think which is smart yeah and much more
mad I think so maybe it's three or five
but he
he's like there's a secret path around
the back and there's like four trails at
Mount Fuji and he's told me to go up
this secret one where we'll probably get
eaten by there's like no one's secret
it's a sheer Cliff this episode will
probably come out after the climb
don't come up the secret Trail but yeah
we're gonna get moved by a bear instead
yeah there's gonna be no one there but I
think this secret Trail and a good
secret Trail Secrets he's got 25 the
footfall of the main route right and but
it's a little bit steeper and it's
supposed to be the hardest way which is
why it's the secret it's not so much
you've made a video on it yeah it's not
so much the secret route as the death
rate because this is a vertical [__]
climb up a volcanic it's free climbing
quicker if we survive yes they'll find
my co-ops a lot quicker but uh yeah it
is what it is Christmas corpse and all
around them is just his books
forever
he's going to collect them well speaking
of book of book of books that's the sort
of grammar you can expect of single book
I do have a copy fun fact when I go on
trash day so I take my belt off wow
she's official chips they've sit down
for like three hours did you have
another two portions anyway
that cover is so clean by the way it's
nice I was Mr affable there before that
I was no not last year Barry Chopsticks
very Chopsticks
this year best-selling author Sunday
Times best-selling author Barry
Chopsticks and let me check if yeah
that's for you guys thank you so much
Chris
10 years in the Land of the Rising Sun I
could only carry like one book oh I
already got mine oh my God
you can get yours at the top of my
future what the [__] you next Wednesday
midday and it's signed by the author you
can get you can get yours at the website
it's signed it'll be worth at least
three pounds one day oh great yeah you
can you it's because it's got the author
signature in it you can sell it for more
sure so kind of so Connor wins uh when's
your next Charity Auction
[Laughter]
one [__] up with the book
oh yeah so obviously I wrote it was six
months it's gone off right you don't
just sit down bash our book in a weekend
yeah well I tried oh this is Stephen
King
chapter five Mr dick
oh my God a literature Masterpiece
brought in Japan
when I read chapter Mr Dick I was left
in tears
[Laughter]
I was gonna say hey the big [__] I I
wrote the chapters in a rush and then I
thought penguin cycling no I thought
yeah because I was so big with you and I
thought penguin would be like let's just
check the chapter they didn't they just
literally kept in the ones I was like
well we'll think about the chapter later
so look at the chapter list page the
front many [__] snow
yeah
that's a nastyism right there let me uh
all right read out these chapter names
all right let me see chapter one Sushi
Revelation the Japan lottery sweet and
San hot springs and tiny cars Mr Dick
sake onigashimasu
[Laughter]
uh when teaching goes wrong many [__]
snow The Impossible language
it's party time after that
give up on the language go party that's
like I've done my work yeah all right
the Land of the Rising waistline
uh all right Hostess clubs and the Art
of expensive companionship okay get out
now uh that's a good chapter all right
uh Japan's most eccentric man the wise
men of Fuji Doctor Who uh I believe
that's uh
oh Jesus Christ okay yes again the BBC
won't be calling it's all right uh fried
uh Fried Chicken addicted bear the worst
possible start a letter from the colonel
saying goodbye can you guess well that's
about to see I I when I got my first KFC
Christmas bucket yeah because you get
Christmas in Japan right yeah you open
it up and it's just a left it's like a
letter from the colonel I'm like well
let it from Colonel somewhere you flip
it over it's like put it in the
microwave it's literally the letter from
the colonel put the [__] chicken in the
microwave and then saying goodbye
starting over Cat Nation a home at last
missiles incoming grounds it what were
we living
[Applause]
uh seeking redemption in a lost year
disappearing Kyoto this is my dream fear
and earthquake Chris I don't see a
chapter about meeting trash tasters
book part two acknowledgment
acknowledgments Are We There are we in
the acknowledgment section at least oh
wow wow that's a good book you should
definitely yeah I've got one yeah where
can they buy us Amazon glamor sales
water stains all major book retailers
it's not all right well it will be I
think when this comes out but it wasn't
on Amazon us because they like penguin
are like we'll see it because it's
penguin UK and they're like we'll see if
we get a book deal book Bill a book deal
in America right and I was like sure so
they didn't I don't think they did and
then they just they released it
themselves but it meant when I was
promoting the book there was nothing on
Amazon us for the time they were working
out and somebody when this [__] cover
was released somebody screenshotted it
put it under an account called like Todd
lb and people started buying the fake
abroad in Japan book oh [__] so they
would get this and it's like a really
crappy like 7-Eleven print job yeah open
it up and inside the book
was a technical guide for breastfeeding
whether you learn that it's like well if
that was just the first edition what
what I learned in Japan chapter one
secrets to breastfeeding that's just
like I got these really sad like
Instagram messages people like I was
really excited to get your book why was
it about breastfeeding
that is the secret of Japan but we got
that book taker down now so don't you
have any [__] thoughts about getting
them yeah don't do that but I don't know
I wanted the only thing I want now is to
be a Sunday Times bestseller so I can
have it you just said you were well and
I don't think we are yet because why are
you claiming you're a Sunday Times best
well we might be if people buy the book
you could just keep saying I can't say
I'm a New York Times bestseller in 20
years but I'm gonna make the book
well yeah oh I see why you wanted to
come on now after like eight months oh I
see well lots of promos
well you will get the Sunday Times
bestseller nickname if you actually
become it you know yeah what will the
nickname be until then you're still very
jobs Barry Chopsticks best but yeah